[Musique]
et
dimitri de la roc la tour bonjour
bonjour du rhône hic mercier d'être sur
le plateau de tv 78 à l'occasion d'une
exposition de photographies qui a eu à
versailles vous êtes multi facettes
j'ai envie de dire vous avez
on vous connaît sur tv 60,18 parce que
vous avez réalisé
comme on dit une émission c'était quoi
ce que vous faisiez oui en fait j'allais
la rencontre de personnalités pour leur
demander quel avait été leur vocation et
c'est un peu la même chose avec les
lieux finalement je vais voir les lieux
pour quelques heures des interviewés
leur demandait quelle est leur vocation
à talant tous ces lieux mystérieux dont
on ne sait pas vraiment d'ailleurs
qu'elle était l'heureux original
d'accord alors moi je remonte un peu
dans le temps vous étiez à la bruyère à
l'époque c'est là que vous avez commencé
cette web tv et qui après donc à est
passé aussi sur tv 78 vous êtes
actuellement étudiant en histoire
voilà je rentre tout à l'heure au
masters en master très bien et vous êtes
aussi donc photographe apparemment
encore une nouvelle casquette
depuis quand est ce que vous faites de
la photo au depuis en fait assez
longtemps
disons que ça fait huit ans que
j'assemble quelques pièces d'un puzzle
et que depuis un an véritablement je
commence à donner une cohérence à tout
ce travail est doux l'exposition à cette
expression est là lui à versailles elle
s'appelle le génie des lieux et je vous
propose qu'on regarde un petit clip qui
illustre très bien voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
oh
alors dimitri de la roc la tour donc
nous venons de voir une petite vidéo un
petit clip qui illustre votre exposition
de photographies donc qu'ils aient lieu
à versailles en ce moment même à
l'université interâges jusqu'au 29
septembre
voilà je vois un petit peu se dépêcher
pour aller la voir alors racontez moi
vous j'ai l'impression vous mêler à la
fois votre passion pour l'histoire et
votre passion pour la photographie dans
cette exposition
oui exactement et puis c'est tout c'est
pour ça que je me rapprochais cela des
interviews qui est cette idée d'aller
vraiment essayé de chercher quelque
chose qui est caché sous les apparences
et pour en revenir à ces fameuses
pierres sacrées j'ai découvert alors ces
mégalithes en fait dont je parlais au
début pour vous dire quelle est la
vocation des lieux finalement et les
mégalithes on ne sait pas tellement
elles contiennent du si des fragments de
silicone et de cristal or on retrouve
des fragments de silicone écrit sale
dans nos ordinateurs aujourd'hui qui
servent à recevoir et diffuser des
informations comme on attribue ce
pouvoir la cépière donc en fait nos
ancêtres ont inventé le cloud en quelque
sorte donc ce sont toutes ces petites
anecdotes sur les lieux que j'essaye de
trouver à chaque fois ya beaucoup de
légendes notamment voix des châteaux
évidemment qui ont tous leurs fantômes
les forêts alors je j'essaye est assez
sensible pour ça peut-être donc c'est et
puis les forêts ont toutes des faits
enfin c'est qu'ils sont extraordinaires
de voyager comme ça d'accord et alors du
coup cette expression le génie des lieux
qui étaient souvent employés vous vous
la voulez exprimer comment alors le
génie des lieux alors évidemment le
génie d'abord c'est le genius lucky des
romains c'est l'esprit protecteur du
lieu chaque civilisation d'ailleurs
avait voilà parfois ce sont des anges
parfois ce sont des faits mais disons
que chaque lieu à son protecteur
protecteur alors voilà il à son
protecteur et puis évidemment il est
habitée par quelque chose comme ce
château de talcy ou pierre de ronsard
était tombé amoureux de cassan de la
fille du maître des lieux et il lui a
écrit le fameux poème mignonne allons
voir si la rose donc on imagine ronsard
encore éperdument amoureux d'une
cassante qui malheureusement ne l'aimé
pas et est là comment vous avez choisi
tous et ses châteaux tous ces lieux
historiques vous avez
suivi quelle ligne un elfe il a alors
justement ce fil des légendes se vit
aussi de l'éloquence évidemment je
préfère les châteaux en ruine
plutôt que les palettes un pan comme par
exemple pierrefonds qui a été magnifique
enfin restaurer d'une façon qu'on peut
apprécier différemment mais voilà j'aime
beaucoup ses palais ses châteaux en
ruine ses forêts sombres
il ya quelque chose dans cette
exposition d'un voyage initiatique
on commence d'ailleurs par les châteaux
qui sont comme des citadelles qui
défendent des terres interdites une fois
qu'on a franchi ses châteaux on arrive
dans les forêts sombres
puis la forêt plus clair ça crée des
celtes les abbayes et on termine dans
des jardins paradisiaque on a atteint
notre destination
alors ça vous avez quel âge 21 ans 21
ans donc ça fait sept ans que vous
faites de la photo et vous travaillé sur
ce projet donc vous avez démarré a alors
du coup j'avais 14 ans oui même un petit
peu avant puisque en fait cet attrait
pour les légendes
ça vient seulement on a on avait on a
toujours une maison de campagne en
normandie à côté de la forêt de lyons
qui est la plus belle et très d'europe
on va voir d'ailleurs un moment une
photo et le hêtre est censé être l'arbre
des faits par son étymologie et c'était
voilà la forêt est au coeur de cette
forêt il y à l'abbaye de mortemer elle
qui est considéré comme l'abbaye la plus
hantée de france et d'ailleurs le musée
des légendes et des fantômes alors il ya
toute une mise en scène avec des
tableaux de dames blanches etc
et quand j'étais petit on y aller et je
tenais ma mère pour qu'on y aille à
chaque vacances donc seulement qu'à
cette époque là j'ai commencé également
à l'a happé par le génie des lieux alors
on parle des faits qui se penche sur un
berceau
voilà c'était quelques génies des dames
blanches peut-être en tout cas ça se
voit être celle pour un magnifique
résultat l'or noir et blanc couleurs on
voit les deux alors oui le noir et blanc
c'est de l'infrarouge alors l'infrarouge
d'ailleurs vous le voyez ses quelque
vingt pas sur ces normes ses couleurs
mais des couleurs volontairement
crépusculaire c'est une oeuvre
importante au crépuscule et pour voir
les fantômes et settat mais sinon le
le l'infrarouge rend un effet de clair
de lune
évidemment c'est difficile de réaliser
en tout cas pas ce qui me concerne des
photos la nuit sous la pleine lune alors
avec l'infrarouge à la le ciel qui est
bleu alors en l'occurrence voilà mais
sinon apparaît noir l'herbe blanc
l'herbe verte apparaît blanche
il ya un côté oui de vision sous la lune
tout semble baigner par la clarté
lunaire est ça le renforce le côté
onirique ce côté mystérieux et alors
c'est malheureusement elles sont
numériques j'aimerais qu'elle soit à
l'ancienne dans l'alchimie de la chambre
noire
mais pour des raisons techniques des
raisons budgétaires au cij pour
l'instant c'est numérique et j'attends
d'avoir un peu plus de rien de moyens et
puis que kodak parce que ces quotas qui
ne commercialise plus sa pellicule infra
rouge depuis 2006 sont là pour l'instant
je fais du numérique
ok on voit apparaître parfois une
danseuse
oui à qui est elle alors c'est une
danseuse que j'ai rencontrés lors d'une
remise de prix et on était tous les deux
pris mais elle pour la danse bon mois
pour la photo et noir dont je vous coupe
justement c'est votre deuxième
exposition photo oui en fait la première
vous avez été près mais loeb alors
c'était en fait là la première alors
j'ai eut exposé quelques photos à paris
dans une librairie où mozart attendons
près après sinon c'était en fait une
exposition
c'était une fut un concours qui est
organisé par le crous j'ai envoyé une
pénalité sauvage alors j'ai envoyé la
photo d'ailleurs qui orne les affiches
de l'exposition accueille une affiche
d'ailleurs qui déclenche parfois les
gens adorent ou détestent voilà il ya
parce que le à travers le personnage est
tellement c'est vrai la danse dont parle
voilà le personnage a l'air tellement
sévères c'est le génie des lieux mais le
protecteur on sent qu'il faut pas
commettre des bêtises dans celui aussi
non donc est ce personnage sauvage
évidemment que caché au coeur d'une
fontaine a eu le premier prix et c'est
ça qui justement j'ai ressorti toutes
les photos elle a été prise il ya sept
ans cette photo et du coup j'ai ressorti
tout cette fois toutes ces fautes en dix
ans mais il ya peut-être cohérence
quelque chose à donner je re sortie
voilà en gros des tiroirs de mes disques
durs mais toutes ces photos d'accord oui
donc c'est pas c'est après coup que vous
dit ça ya une cohérence et il ya
vraiment une j'avais cette affinité
j'avais cette affinité avec les lieux
évidemment d'histoire enfin je suis
étudiant en histoire d'ô lucide il ya
quand même quelque chose
voilà j'ai cogné j'ai fait la connexion
des points comme on dit et puis c'est a
paru une évidence que je continue cet
été par exemple la gt en irlande j'ai
été l'année dernière en auvergne en
bretagne aussi avec ses fameuses pierres
dans le pays de brocéliande parce que
mon un de mes preuves
sa fille est mon premier prénom j'allais
dire heureusement pas c'était merlin
appelé berlin et on lui a dit non que
voilà je m'appelle dibiterie mais disons
que sur ma carte d'identité c'est
toujours marqué merlin au premier prénom
donc peut-être que donc sa part a
quelquefois sur au flottement
voilà pour donner un côté encore plus
abbas et la féerie parce que ça il m'a
guéri voilà on me dit que les photos
sont lugubres
mais c'est pas le lugubre que je
recherche mais comme ce sont des lieux
historiques évidemment il s'est passé
des drames il s'est passé des heures
joyeuse aussi mais c'est noël
voilà c'est une sorte de véhémence de
l'histoire parfois il ya un arbres
décharnés on dirait un squelette
bon j'ai pas cherché à faire du glauque
et il est apparu là il s'était un
tableau en fait ce que je recherche dans
les lieux c'est pour ça qu'à la limite
je préfère les photos que les peintures
dans mon cas c'est parce que la nature
offre déjà tellement de tableau en
elle-même alors je les vois là j'ai
simplement je suis là avec mon appareil
photo je passe car profite et si je
faisais des tableaux on dirait peut-être
ouhlala il a une imagination un peu
malade comment il a inventé tout ça non
ça existe vraiment oui s'il fait de
regarder voilà nous montrer m'écouter
dimitri un grand merci on va se
précipiter donc aller vers site
interâges pour admirer vos photos et
qu'est ce que vous allez faire une
histoire en master j'aimerais bien
justement connectés connecter cette
passion des lieux qui est assez
romantique en fait la passion des lieux
avec des recherches alors ça voilà c'est
très intéressant c'est le château de
rares est un lieu hautement féerique où
ailleurs dans l'oise alors maintenant
c'est les hauts de france enfin la
région la picardie ou jean cocteau a
tourné la belle et la bête en 1945
avec donc jean marais et josette day
dans le rôle de la belle et c'est un
lieu extraordinaire on voit la porte de
la licorne est devant le château
il y à toute une allée avec ds culte et
avec des bustes de divinités antiques
c'est un lieu extraordinaire d'ailleurs
disney quand disney a fait cette année
la belle et la bête il ya des décors
qu'on retrouve de rares est donc c'est
un lieu qui inspire disney aussi alors
les yvelines alors je ne sais pas si on
l'a vu passer peut-être une abbaye des
vaux de cernay
ah oui qui ce qui se trouve tout près
d'ici et le relief une fontaine magique
puisque saint louis la femme de
saint-louis marguerite de provence
souffrait de stérilité
elle convoque la bd votre cerner la b
thibault de marly il a fait boire à une
ode sa fontaine il ya onze enfants qui
naissent dans le fil des années donc
depuis à la fontaine des vox airbaltic
qui est réputé pour ça pour rendre
fertile celle qui malheureusement ne le
sont pas alors les gens le savent
oui elle est bien mise en valeur lyon
ils ont bien une petite coupole dessus
et on peut donc aller au vôtre cerner
même si on ne souffre pas de ses invités
enfin c'est un lieu de toute façon
magnifique enchanteur et parfaite vous
montrer des lieux connus visiter et des
lieux complètement oublié du monde oui
notamment château le château de palluel
en périgord je vous coupe la parole
pardon vous avez décidé de le montrer
oui ces magnifiques photos donc on va
les voir très vite
dimitri a très vite mes autres belles
choses obama
il
[Musique]